[Musique]
notre approche et ça c'est que à la
place de forcer un jeune avec des
besoins particuliers à s'adapter pour
les arts martiaux
on a décidé d'adapter les arts martiaux
à ses besoins autrement dit exemple
quand un jeune de faire du karaté du
judo de la boxe à la place de le forcer
avec les exigences nous sept sports et
le forcer à faire partie d'un groupe qui
s'entraînent déjà bas on a préparé un
environnement où vivre des réussites
avec lui
[Musique]
le besoin à commencer par rapport à une
expérience que j'ai vécu moi-même je
donnais des cours de karaté dans une
zone jaune et c'est là que j'ai eu mon
premier jeunes acquis qu'ils avaient des
besoins particuliers c'était un jeune
avec un diagnostic de thiès les parents
voulaient pas me le dire ça se passait
en 2006 et à la fin de la session ce
jeune là a réussi à avoir sa ceinture
jaune en sachant que les premiers tours
il fallait courir d'un livre en se
plaçant l'huile pour par le salut je me
rappel au début de chaque cours
je me préparais spécialement pour lui
pour qu'il puisse avoir une les
meilleures circonstances pour qu'il
puisse réussir à la fin de la session
les parents sont venus me voir pour me
dire on s'excuse on nous a menti
notre fils et tué son fils a menti
simplement parce qu'il s'est fait
refuser de toi salle de sport avant de
venir s'inscrire ici et on a des ports
comme vous allez le refuser si on vous
disait qu'il utilise
[Musique]
e
quand je me suis renseigné sur l'autisme
gr
dire sa définition c'est des personnes
avec des problèmes de communication et
de socialisation dit bah moi je viens
d'arriver à montréal
et comme immigrants reçus j'ai les mêmes
problèmes de communication et de
socialisation
ça va ça va vraiment amené à -b à
travers ce jeune toute cette clientèle
est principalement à les deux tiers de
la clientèle de notre association c'est
d'une personne avait un trouble
[Musique]